yeah drink that coffee Rob you're gonna
need it for these colossi though we're
gonna have to fight so what's up guys
it's Wednesday thanks everyone for
tuning in of course gamespot live here
me Eric that's Rob we're playing Shadow
of the Colossus today came out yesterday
officially the remake the remake and
we're gonna check out New Game+ yeah
which is that what I think you're in
right now so we in theory then we'll
have to fight you know speed through as
many colossi as possible I am I have run
this game so many times now you have it
now I haven't they haven't I am a I'm a
newcomer to this game I just beat it
over the weekend and I absolutely loved
it and this game is absolutely gorgeous
that is really fun so yeah I'm still
living that Monster Hunter life they
gave my friends but ya know this game
looks cool mmm it's it'll be interesting
to get your perspective as somebody that
you know just beat it and played it
through for the first time I actually
haven't really played it outside like
you know like the first boss or whatever
but yeah I'd rather just watch people
play I think yeah for sure mr. Gillie we
were playing on a Playstation 4 Pro
right now yes
what's up Android gamer what's up Israel
King btg ilk gamer Dan Marek and ER and
ER and Eric mmm
Daniel Eubanks Harrison Sweeney thank
you thank you all for tuning in yeah
I'll be in the chat checking out your
messages if you guys have questions
comments etc for me or Rob send them our
way and or my way and I'll get that over
to rob you know what what's up what are
you now that I've played the game on
default look why don't we play with some
of these cool so I monsoon Matic mode
but I want to do just don't do nighttime
though it's like I can't it's really
dark on stream was what I was told we
like here
I want to do warms monster-hunting our
destiny killer potentially if you want
to watch a video watch Mike's video
about I think it's titled like goodbye
destiny hello monster honey jeez are we
watching an old-timey
it's an archaic okay game look at this
bike Oh what happened there
nothing just just saw the eye ball go up
oh you know what it is it's Wednesday
and people think it's la la vie I was
wondering why we have 500 people and on
Twitch whoa because we have that Lobby
promo on Wednesdays whoa yeah hi this is
not the lobby the lobby no longer exists
for those curious we do all these what
we do instead now is we do these kind of
ease fun chats in the office kind of
like cooler talk chats I guess in a way
yeah I've been really enjoying them
myself and they've been pretty fun we've
done a couple now monster hunter world
like is this the first one you should
get into we did a chat on that we did to
chat about you know how dragon ball
again it's like as a really great game
for a very wide audience you know from
the hardcore fighting game community
people to just people that maybe enjoy
the anime we're doing a fortnight one
yeah shortly it should come on the next
day or two and what else is there one
more I'm missing or that it we we're
considering doing a Shadow of the
Colossus well oh right it's kind of like
you know it's nice about obviously all
the people here in the offices you know
people have played this game as people
haven't so yeah it was the idea being
there like you know like myself who's
new this game like just different you
know how does it feel now like coming in
fresh and I really liked it you know the
controls are still kind of finicky yeah
it's got that little bit of jank which
Mike was like yeah I like I think for
him he'd rather just be better now
but for some people I think there's some
nostalgia and the fact that like yeah I
remember these controls yeah I didn't
mind it and like you know they're for
the most part it wasn't too bad I think
the one complaint mate like you
say is maybe the camera work is a little
rough like I played last Guardian and
that was kind of the same thing this
bastard obviously the same creators but
like a lot of those kind of frustrations
are present here I feel like but for the
most part you know it's it's interesting
to with like the horse agro I roll girl
reminds me a lot of Treecko - you know
like it's it's not like a perfect one to
one yeah
control so do you know I mean like
neither of us have that much experience
with New Game+ in this game I'm kind of
curious like if it's like harder or like
what the deal is I know there's some
unlockable stuff that you have to get
through a new game plus I suppose but
like I'm curious if the colossi are any
harder or anything like that it's a good
question yeah I was think about doing
that but I I'm pretty I'm pretty sure my
cuz you know in the game you can get
stamina upgrades and health and I I
think that's one thing that carries over
into New Game+ yeah I should yes Android
gamer it should be $39.99
what's up private cookie I bow 2387
asking what's your guys's favorite
Colossus
I'll let Robb go first I haven't played
or seen too many but I have I have one
from the early earlier ones yeah I had
one I believe it's the 13th colossi okay
and I'm thinking maybe we'll play a
little of this new game plus to see if
like it's any different and then I have
I do have a save a save on the 9th
colossi so jump over to that good get
maybe play like 30 40 minutes of this
couple do couple on you game plus see if
they're different for you not maybe
we'll go back and check out some other
Colossus freaking 13 for you yeah it's
not even doing it justice here in this
classic vintage mode here for me from
what I saw so far
I liked that aerial boss that the fifth
boss I think you like the like the water
like you know everything you think you
would have to do to get on it isn't
actually how you get on it I guess yeah
I remember Mike saying like oh yeah you
haven't seen anything yet just wait
you see this bus I think any flying boss
in this game would probably well my mind
there is another one yeah there's like a
huge the huge snake one looking one in
the you know and the trailers and stuff
like that I'm sure that one yeah and the
desert crazy yeah that one's pretty
freakin cool I believe that's like that
didn't seem very much harder on your
game Plus granny first boss so you know
yeah yeah nailed it so caught her games
I think part of it is so you're trying
to save who would I assume is like your
girlfriend and she's like kind of like
dead and so you're like basically made a
bargain and said like okay I will go
hunt these Colossus because that is the
only way I can bring her back to life
and I heard you know I I already know in
my head like how this ends I don't want
to spoil it but like obviously there's
there's got to be a trade-off right you
know there's guy there's gotta be
something you don't sure you don't get
anything for free is how I look at it
you happier even if you're going to kill
the monsters yeah nothing comes free you
know just just like in real life yeah
pretty much unless you actually find a
free deal in which case sure exactly but
you know what I mean for sure and you
know what I was I would say that I had
the same idea and then it wasn't that no
it was that bucket blood with so much
more so much worse so much more I heard
he got emotional yes oh yeah girlfriend
wife same thing okay sorry wife I didn't
realize it was his wife but oh it's
essential that's not really the same
thing
you could be dating a girlfriend for
like you know six months a year but you
know would stream on Wednesday will just
be a regular thing for the timing yes
farik's the cat we will I'm gonna try to
make sure we're we're live every day
Monday to Friday at 11 a.m. as mentioned
if you guys saw last Friday Sam was on a
stream with oh nice with I need of this
room Joey and you might see a little bit
more Sam throughout the week potentially
so stay tuned for that if you if you
enjoyed watching her host:2 shame she
why host and and/or play at different
times but yeah maybe someone in the chat
knows I'm pretty sure I read this online
is that so you can do this badass move
stay
yeah and then get on that Hawk I think
there's I think there's another move we
can get on the side of it beside of
aggro I don't know I don't know how to
do it though
chances go to that second boss though
it's a crab guy right the crab guy and
it's not the crab guy I just think if
he's on the Kratt a crab guy because
he's on the you know the beach near the
water it's definitely not in that crowd
he's like a bull I know that yeah
there's like a like a you know like an
office name for like all of these guys
they're kind of because a lot of these
class I are you know reminiscent of
actual animals yes crab mmm there's like
a giraffe looking one later
yeah and of giraffe bird uh-oh Oh broken
nose or I'll just call you broken I've
never played this franchise but it looks
fun my question is is it a really
difficult game um from the knowledge I
know and I'll ask Rob here in a second
what did it's like the the colossi
ramped up in terms of difficulty in
terms of like how you beat them it it's
kind of more like a puzzle you know way
than it is like a like an action game I
mean like yeah you're you're mounting
the colossi or climbing the colossi to
hurt their weak spots mhm but generally
it's it's some type of puzzle that you
have to solve then those points or you
know things like that right you know and
there are the doorman hints where it's
like kind of like the sentient demon
voice that kind of guides you it's you
know the devil you made a pact with and
he'll chime in once in a while like if
he can get a sense that you're having a
little difficulty I just turn those off
so bad only a few times toward the later
class I turn them on
yeah just to get like you know it's
amazing it's like a riddle yeah so
there's a little bit of that but the
other thing I would say is stamina more
often than a few times I die but like
more often not it was a matter of
stamina so like you know they're shaking
you off some of the later ones I get
really like it gets really tough yeah
and you have to act quicker in order to
get through those puzzles or to like
interact with you know their weak spot
huh
so like there was a couple of class I
were like I was too slow to get to a
position and then he he would like be
relentless and shaking me off but it's
all fun like malevolent spirits is what
the real McCoy says come on guy close
enough it's his first time like going
through the game
how are you thank you for that hello to
all the people saying hello including
Elijah Turner awesome turtleman as
mentioned for the person I'm sorry that
I missed your name like ruff they were
asking like how long it takes it's
roughly like 8 to 10 hours unless like
you're just like really blowing by and
like know what to do probably again
Jordan than that shorter if you know I
would say it took me about 10 going in
real blind and that was can you sign
treadle boner ooh baby and whatever I
bow 2387 yeah I agree the flying desert
cloth I've lost is part of my favorite -
YUM
mine is and if chat can name I think
it's the 13th I don't know the name of
it but it's like a what took a water you
got it yeah a water guy show me show me
your feet I think that bone arrow is is
top okay so what Mike did is he just
hopped off the horse
oh and got it that way and just shot it
that way oh for sure that's was easy it
was easier because because can you shoot
your bone you should be able to be right
okay yeah yeah good but doesn't this
horsey is just way I would be afraid if
I was horse you got this thing
stampeding like a why the hell would I
want to get near that he's a tough
cookie this is the new version em dragon
it came out yesterday on the ps4
I believe 39 and 99 okay he's down now
you gots to climb him where's your fur
baby nope oh my god see how could all
give me a second I don't know man
what's party if you can get up to that
platform before he gets angry well you
have a good amount of down yeah a real
dothraki fires a bow from his horse
kappa face there it is can't take you
seriously thanks everyone for tuning in
though appreciate it especially all
money twitch folks we're live every day
at 11 a.m.
GameSpot's yep live so yeah
hit that follow button if you haven't
come on baby come on
I feel like I'm corners here why you see
I'm like totally going on dude
got it nailed it
Wow what a bold man that was a bold move
cotton not even regaining your stamina
there oh this is embarrassing and you
beat this game on a scale of one to ten
how hard is it I since I haven't beat it
you'd have to ask Rob I you know what
I'm just gonna throw out a number I bet
you it's like a six I don't know it's
the last one seven all right class the
last class I was pretty tough took me a
while he definitely is epic as well nice
broken off topic why did y'all close the
show the lobby loved watching it um we
just decided that there was other stuff
we wanted to explore in 2018 and as you
guys know the lobby did and you know
take a fair amount of people to kind of
like be on that show and kind of like
having the ability for some of these
folks like Mike to make some other cool
pieces like his a destiny goodbye
destiny hello monster world peace during
the week so those are some of the
reasons but you know I appreciate you
guys tuning in and enjoying the show and
sharing your feelings maybe one day
it'll come back or something who knows
are you playing on a pro yes we are what
are you doing on that monster you know
we're climbing it right now he has an
itch we have to save our I guess wife is
what I'm being told
look Marshall won't you chill there
why'd you just chill there for a second
wrong okay or not no no you're fine and
so he's being tasked to kill these
colossi because there he's been told if
he does that he can have his wife back
so yeah that's that's why he's doing it
you know got him over the love of his
life would you do it Rob would you kill
six is it sixteen thirteen
there's sixteen fifteen would you kill a
sixteen you know Masai I'd save your
wife I'd have to really love her you
know she's your wife Rob how if you
don't really love her how did you even
marry her to begin with sure but just
saying she's Rob's future wife good luck
hold on for your life oh look he loves
it
I'm pretty sure he doesn't like being
stabbed in the forehead but okay yes in
the itch and your it says Keith Richards
liver 420 yeah it's gonna need a bath
yes anvil one gaming these animals are
probably minding their own business and
we're the ones kind of you know well
encroaching on their territory it is
kind of sad like yeah you don't feel
great about killing these dudes because
the music chime it's mainly the music
it's very kind of depressing like dass
von Luber schnitzel wants to know how
does it run is it buggy like Guardian no
I mean the cameras a little not it's not
buggy is it's just not great and then
the movements probably a little it's got
that little old-school jank you know but
yeah I think Peter Brown made a good
point which is like you know in order to
kind of praise the game you kind of want
to leave some of that stuff in there you
know I mean yeah the people that oh it's
it's probably most most of the players
or probably the people that played you
know either the older remake or their
original and are now coming back to this
you know remake of this game more so
than new players playing it right right
so you know you got to keep some of that
come just keep some of that in there so
by the end of it you're gonna have 16
shadowy spirits just like staring at you
right yeah that's so dark it is dark you
freed us just kidding no you didn't
though I know kind of pick apparently
it's this the the language that they're
speaking is like a mix between like
Japanese
Native American oh really yeah okay so
do you guys think however Rheem is do
you think we will ever see a remake of
Eko
uh I don't know hard to say Ivo someone
was saying that bluepoint who did this
this remake is always onyx on to another
game yeah and people are trying to guess
what it could be they're like oh what if
it's Demon Souls
you know because but I don't see it
being demon souls only because Dark
Souls about to be remastered and that's
in May I think but then someone was like
what if they're just actually working on
Dark Souls and that's a thing and I'm
like oh that kind of makes sense I guess
but other people are thinking maybe it's
eco I don't know me don't know I'd be
I'd be cool with eco cuz I haven't
played that one yeah yeah I heared that
ones up Stacy Sinclair here that one's
also like a little frustrating in a way
cuz I believe the game like one of the
core mechanics is you're like carrying
someone around and there's a lot of
puzzles with that mm-hmm
what's up Moomin thanks for tuning in
Nathan Shepherd asking so what's new in
new game+ I believe there's a bunch of
like stuff you can get that you can only
get in new game+ but don't necessarily
quote me on that
you're so again in this game you you
know you kill lizards and lizards and
eat their tails and pick fruit for
health
lizards are for stamina that carries
over so kind of like your upgrades do so
like yeah like I mean having played this
game now replaying it like I definitely
feel like I'm taking these guys down
quicker what is a flying fondant look
like flying fauna yeah is that different
from that bird we saw I think that maybe
is anyways you can grab on to those
because you were saying that you could
grab onto this oh the bow the might be
ICO I think ICO is probably the better
what yeah I think it's ICO DC Co 209
thank you for the e I think it's ICO
sorry I didn't play that game either I'm
a casual what can I say
when did that game come out I go yeah
let me tell you it's also crazy how long
Last Guardian took remember like when it
was first announced in like I want to
say like 2012 what
with that long yeah I remember it being
a really long time Aiko came out 2001
2001 oh uh so riding Oh on the side is
hold down our one in triangle hold down
our one and try and then push the left
analog stick where you want to lean our
one triangle and left stick either left
or right I guess then I'll work I'm
doing it
are those older controls no shouldn't be
R 1 is 1 is R 1 and X work right now the
galloping thing where you stand on R 1
is this yeah but how do you okay so how
do you use how to stand like this yeah
but what was the button prompt for that
so that's our - oh okay maybe it's maybe
says you have different ones on I don't
know maybe try our two and triangle that
in our two triangle that work and then
the left and on the state yeah no that's
just gonna turn me all right well then
I'm an idiot then don't say that yeah
that's what I read um also there's like
time attack modes where you can get
rewards you get a whistling arrow you
can get a cloak of force massive
strength just lizard detection stone
this map is also huge and if like it's
cool what's cool is I think there's like
multiple ways to get to each class I
like this is a different way as
adventure calls yes there are four
different control types are you going to
the right area to feel like okay alright
I don't like yeah Gracie let's YouTube
how long is this stream gonna be roughly
an hour to 90 minutes we'll see how it
goes I don't know where the naughty
girls are at and then I'm not agree I
don't know I haven't seen a scam I
haven't seen any in life
yeah okay I'm here you made it
oh is this a guy with a sword this guy
is sick he's like one of the ones I feel
like is on the cover and everything I
haven't seen too much difference yet
elec senator Amidala in terms of new
game+ i just know that there's some
stuff you're supposed to be able to get
that you can't get in normal mode you
can get so yeah when you do Time Attack
and you any beat colossi you know the
time set like I know like some were like
you know beat in under two minutes or
something like that you do get like
different types of arrows I think is one
that where you can hear the whistling
arrow but more easily distract them do
you have didn't you game Plus to do that
though or can you just do Time Attack
after the fact you go back so like I
think I can go back now uh-huh to that
first guy and do its - Zach yeah okay
it's right now I have it on performance
mode so it's gonna smoother locked
framerate but I for one like the
cinematic mode all right I guess if chat
actually knows they can help me out
otherwise I will continue to scour the
internet to find out we feel like let's
do a little stool a little emerald oh
that's real nice oh wow look at that
there's also one so for instance this
guy he's okay so within New Game+ you
can try the time attack mode so yes you
do need that I guess okay I know there's
other things which like beat this guy I
think in order to just so you know in
order and everyone in chat in order to
start a time attack you need to kneel
and pray before one of the colossi in
the shrine of worship this will let you
tackle a challenge and completing them
will get you unlocks there's two sets of
rewards between normal and hard time
attack mode so in normal as you
mentioned the Whistling arrow is one of
them where you can distract them
anyways you were gonna say yeah I think
there's something else where certain
class I like this guy right he there's a
big like an iron plate in the middle
where you want to break off his armor
yep by having him hit down on it I
believe you get like an unlock or
something if you don't do that because I
there's you can also it's more difficult
you can also just climb up and that's
what I was doing like my yeah I was
talking like he's like oh you didn't do
that I was like no I actually just
totally just climbed around it right
there's a yeah well I think I saw a hole
in the armor last time which we were
trying to do but Mike wanting to do it
his way
hit me oh that wind up the homerun so
how are you gonna do it are you gonna do
it I'm gonna do it my way
so it works alright I like it the badass
way I like it
this guy has such wanderer has a great
you know bow way to Zeke you know yeah
is that the hole right there yeah so you
can climb a walking climb through that
or no oh there's a hole odds are you're
sexy like above you I don't know if you
could fit through there what you see
that you see through that do you I'm
pretty sure you're gonna jump across
yeah oh there's that camera work what a
badass come on he kind of raises a
little bit uh you can't spin it right
you can't you know blew it you don't you
can't spin it what you mean you can't
control the camera right there to see
from like another angle
well that's thing is you're kind of
battling it that's that's where the
camera gets like super finicky okay
there are multiple ways to defeat the
Colossus kind of I'm pretty sure because
I remember Mike did something with the
lot the the fourth boss that somebody
was like oh I didn't even know you could
beat it that way
ty and I think he had like tricked it to
look up one hole so then he could climb
up the other side or something whereas
the other person was like oh I used the
horse to climb up on him or something
so there must be multiple ways because
as Rob mentioned he beat this boss
without ever having the colossus hit
that giant plate there because that's
how you get him to lose his armor is you
want him to smack the iron plate and
then that kind of like shakes off that
like you know that ring I don't know
bracelet racer whoa that he has on there
it would fall off if he hit the if he
hit the thing but there is a way I'm
pretty sure unless I like accidentally
or didn't even notice I had knocked it
off but like like this yeah yeah yeah I
like it okay now what can you jump up
high enough to get to the next so yeah I
think actually I did it like oh here's
but it's a tight but sick foot alright
probably pros a bud probably but hey we
respect your opinion
dammit don't you have enough stamina
though right I don't get it well I'm
trying to get to his other leg and then
I can climb up yeah I'm pretty sure okay
let's try it one more time let me see
that six or did gosh darn it
hit me gee golly wilikers oh you know
what I do all right I think I know did
it what I can jump back okay okay don't
let him hit that iron plate then Oh
Nelly I'm here come get me
get on that sword okay and it's kind of
weird hey man I'm not I'm honest I'm not
a pro you tell me Rob I'm on a speed
runner I got some tricks up my sleeve Oh
can't you walk up the feet
I don't think so they're circular but
maybe Andy will just continue to let Rob
try to do it the way he believes is
right in which case we we always know
that the deep the default will be just
to have him hit the iron plate
because that'll make it that'll be super
easy obviously but he wants to try it
his way which is cool at like two more
tries of this I'll probably be like yeah
that's enough of that let's just get to
the next boss or try Time Attack no dude
yeah dude chats grinding there chief
all right try one more yeah I try one
more time you can go up the leg that
says real McCoy
sick there you go nope fell off man he's
so cool
until he smacks you good yeah all right
here we go
no problem no problem no problem no the
other way right well I mean I'm it's I
always [ __ ] fighting it like it is
finicky damn the camera just goes right
into it you love it huh Oh still good
you sweating a little bit you can't see
it bring me closer you are as close as
you're gonna get oh no no no really he
gets closer you like it alright that's
pretty good
okay I'm fighting this control ass dude
yeah that's what you get to get for not
doing it the normal way I'll give you
one more chance and then if that doesn't
work I want you just to let him hit the
iron plate or we can just go to move
right along well we can't really move
right along because do you think you
have to beat the monster before you can
pray at the shrine for the time attack
like now that you beat those other two
colossi so that's things like that would
mental way right yeah I can go back yeah
but remember when we when we first open
the save it didn't work when the the
shrines were still there you know I mean
when you had not defeated a claw sighs
yeah yeah the Colossus isn't colossi
like not singular I'm seeing it plural a
Colossus I think when in doubt just keep
saying colossi because it sounds good
yeah when can we expect gse emotes I
don't know actually I did not oh did not
plan for them come on use those yoga
skills all right that was sick I read
colossi is plural no yeah I think it is
colossi would be plural yeah Colossus
would be singular so after you beat
certain Colossus know you get colossi
after we beat certain colossi you would
then be able to tech I think do Time
Attack at that point on those colossi
god damnit
I don't understand
oh I'm just bad at this game I guess
well how did you do it the first time
Eric I wish I could nail it well like I
said in the very worst case you got that
brass plate tactic so you know who knows
was grammar uh yeah good thing I'm not
editorial right huh my original name is
this game out yet or what yeah I came
out yesterday rip in pepperonis what
will you do now Rob I'm just having to
hit the plate I'm just gonna freakin
suck it up and just do it just hit me
what just just hit me dude you do we
want to skip to like because I know
there's class I I don't know if you I
have to I'm saying is that right I have
a save for like the ninth yeah yeah but
like I want you to do a Time Attack okay
or try a Time Attack I guess I think I
messed that up
oh wait no I think you got it yep maybe
you did break his thing and not and not
have known I feel oh really okay well
that's fair
hey yo God that sound effects are so
cool
well whoo I feel you should believe in
your capabilities Rob whoo that's kind
of you to say the real McCoy but I I
doubt it exactly make Rob play this game
seriously I'm pretty sure he's playing
seriously oh no I'm just oh you oh you
guys want me to try okay yeah that's
that's the best it's like you know when
you're losing this someone you're like
huh I haven't even you haven't even seen
my final form yet I've really I've just
been playing relax my my dad would do
that with Mario Kart 64 either he got
first me be like I can't tell what
number that that is what does that on
the screen is that good or if he lost me
like oh do you want me to try and as a
kid when I would be like dad I really
don't like you exactly all right all
right now you go to the left get your
stamina back and climb the rest of his
arm and it's easy peasy right lemon
squeezy
so after this maybe we'll try going back
to the shrine will why'd you do that
because there's an Owen stomach all
right his belly button
yeah and if you got to do the first one
first okay I almost thought the game was
gonna troll you and make you go to the
head first Rob's dad has swag I know
right
I know he's like get off my belly button
you look my jack now we know where Rob
got his awesome sense of humor that I
thought it was his [ __ ] stamp but it
wasn't it was just a belly button taste
final form yeah you haven't seen it
oh yeah I don't know if anyone will ever
see it myself included oh look he loves
it in Rob's dad's day it was called
swagger nice yeah well played that's
rock though you need some fur get or not
rock but this is like actual skin this
is leather
climb climb out of the three monsters so
far which one would you be and why that
definitely
guy cuz he's tall and has a weapon like
it wasn't very hard to choose from in my
opinion but hey now maybe you want to be
a bull or that other really slow
brooding guy oh I like the hooves guy
he's alright it's kind of he's gone
seems like I take him some time to get
around the world
this guy could like walk over valleys in
the [ __ ] like that don't work Oh like
what what are you get off my head
uh-oh I just need to smack his head you
know oh oh man the hair so cool oh
you're running a scams I'm showing maybe
I'm not you're definitely not sir you're
mildly making me nervous here yeah we're
good a good guy Rob and you did regain
his stamina instead of trying to go for
the win he'll fall off whoa
Oh get off me
wanders I have lice his wrists your lice
would so break off when he's doing like
360s oh come on dude dude hold on oh
yeah gube stabbed his head at PSX well
Rob stabbing his head today
on a Wednesday did you barely I know
right I guess I gotta line up
you're like tickling him get this tattoo
removed shake it baby oh I know it's not
that hard but I don't know any other
monsters so I'll ask it again in a bit
that's that's better cuz ask me and I'll
be that bird thing Oh Robert you're
making me nervous
good thing Wanderers got great core
strength apparently can you can get
different colors on the agri of the
horse a girl oh I'm stood I know right
hey how's a nice one squirt out the
shadowy blood we end us all one more
oh no nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
I'm not taking a break okay thank you
wow you went for it huh yeah Dylan
Rudy Rudy Rudy enjoying the game
question
look at that stream I'd say to you
enjoying the game who me yeah oh yeah I
love this game I like once I finish I
definitely like wanted to play again but
maybe I'll take a break well break it
can't escape do I did once I have done
things over I didn't so what do you want
to do now are you gonna try to see if
you can do a Time Attack thing
what do you try to see if that works
aren't sure in theory let's see with it
let's see what looks like and then try
going back to your old save and playing
some of the farther we moon stutters
Android Colossus jump we can jump to 9 I
don't think they like being called
monsters they're Colossus their people
their animal people while you're killing
them Rob a lot of that I like cutscene
reminds me of Last Guardian - I know ICO
and this scoop this is a prequel to ICO
but I like the tie-ins to Last Guardian
or a little more vague the line Expo is
my mother malevolent spirits so like
this like that all I read yeah there you
go
yeah challenge him your goal is two
minutes there is that the guy that you
just bought or the first guy this is the
first guy I do it let's do it two
minutes 30 seconds easy easy alright so
we are trying the time attack mode I
believe to trigger it you have to have
beaten him at least once normally in the
new game plus mode right because when we
went up to another Colossus shrine that
we didn't beat yet I don't think he had
the option to do time attack so as you
can see it's
right assuming I'm not yeah top right
shows what we want to try to aim for in
the time oh yeah
2:30 is the time to beat currently at 11
seconds because this jerk with a mace is
just walking away sir
excuse me sir I'm just kind of roaming I
have 2 minutes and 30 seconds to kill
you to get sweet 2 precious loot let me
stab at your calf nope wrong nope losing
time sword sword me how does that feel
yeah you tickle them cuz it didn't hurt
where are you supposed to oh is that
just to get him to me oh yeah when it's
like misty red it's just a weak spot
it's a little yeah a little weak spot
I'll kill ease action real bros get cab
tats yeah I guess so you could get it oh
all right restart restart retry I don't
you know what I am
I thought 2:30 was gonna be easy I'm
starting to think that it's not that was
am it that was almost a minute and you
weren't even on his back yet does he
have - he has - weak spots alright we're
just once 100k and then maybe it's not
that bad and it's all straight metal I
don't think it's the world record for
the boss I think it's just what the game
wants you to do to help you get like I
think if you pass it you get the item
right I believe there's a a hard yeah
there's a normal and a hard
yes correct whoa that is correct wrong
maybe this time you see already I'm sort
out that's good we don't waste time with
that bow oh you know what else I'm
noticing it's my stamina - oh you don't
have that extra stand that's why I
didn't go so well
I don't think it was that I think you
just didn't get on to the spot you need
to you come on dude I'm like totally
climbing up
hey you're not you're about to run a
stamina hey we did it
okay regain take a little breather Oh
take a little breather you probably need
all of it you got it a minute 30 90
seconds come on Rob bring that a game
link for the game says cheb should have
a day deal cut a breather breather
breather breather for either breather
I'm not I'm not lined up a my time I'm
chillin you got a minute but you are
running on a stamina though okay noted
Rob's gone for the quick stab tactic
here up okay breathe finish I'll come
back Leigh I feel like this is like p90
you're like alright we're gonna do some
intensive all right Wow all right 30
seconds left I am good first guy though
any word on what golden tokens are used
for in this game I don't know I die
maybe people in the chai know I found
playing the game like to just items kind
of hidden like glowing little orbs I
pick them up and I don't know they do
there's no like there's nothing in the
menu boom we did it what do we get right
away like it's like you're spewing it
out of your stomach to you which is kind
of gross but yeah yeah how's that
working out we should get something
right oh you gotta be - to get the
whistling arrow with that alright do one
more do the second boss you can do it I
believe in you so I'll actually try
going to one of those the ones that's
already that you haven't beat I would
assume you can't do Time Attack right
nope no I undertand try it
oh hello so we can check out any
Colossus
yeah we're learning hey hey we were just
dumb before the street I'm doing it
alright alright alright what would you
like to fight Rob well hmm
any one of them now this is awesome this
is now now we're having fun now we're
now we're doing it now this is podracing
Oh God do your favorite boss he says do
my favorite boss okay I had a real well
definitely not gonna make the time I
don't think I should probably do it I
should probably do an easier one right
do you wanna do to you
bird rhyme Rory
ah geez that's a hard name save our ymd
ka kor says streaming is ruining a
single-player gaming I think that um
it's not because it's your choice to
watch any stream so if you don't want to
get spoiled you just avoid the internet
right you just avoid watching a stream
and play the game yourself if you wanna
watch somebody play the game to get a
feel for how that game is gonna you know
be I think streaming is great I think
that it's a way it's like a platform for
people to experience kind of like a
preview or to interact with you know
hosts or people you know outside of
their normal like you know totally
friends and stuff like that hopefully
you become friends with us I mean don't
that's alright hey in this game this
game came out mm oh yeah that's 2005 I
believe God oh is this the fifth boss
yeah yeah this guy's would be the one
I'd want to be yeah for sure I like when
it lands on his little perch I like
everything about this boss yeah yeah
chillin I loved playing these for the
first time learning how to get onto the
sky it was so cool yeah Mike was like I
watch he's not good he's not gonna know
what to do
well it's terrifying right I got five
minutes you think I can do it no I think
you can do it believe in yourself so
look at my stamina like Connor oh you
got locked up yeah automatically so
that's like what they think you should
be at for that I guess for that boss
yeah cuz like the the micro saying that
you swim fat you're faster and wor the
shrines are always kind of which have
the lizards they're always kind of
located near
a colossi so I always feel like I mean
how I was playing is I kind of hit up
one or two before I went on to the big
man okay I'm pretty sure I just shoot
him but I need to get into a good spot
I would assume colossi would still be
the best way to like I don't know a lot
of people are chatting colossi spine but
it is the plural so I am I thought I'm
already doing this wrong I should be I
should be like aren't you supposed to
get out like on a platform or something
and then like fire or something I
remember doing it over you do you I
wonder if it kicks you out if you don't
meet the goal that's all so we'll find
out how feeling we're all gonna miss
this goal you just said I you thought I
could do it I know I'm a fan Wagoner
what can I say
yeah I don't think I can do it okay
where's the platform so you can get a
brown the brown horse but you got to
beat all 16 in normal Wow yeah and then
I think there's a different color
there's a white horse if you do it in
hard yeah
we are fighting a colossus for an
example yeah it's true is it like goose
and geese though right damn it let's not
go down that path let's just not go down
that path I think I can hit him from
over here man a lot of swimming in this
one
alright dude I already just freaking
know what friggin lost two minutes
already did sick
hey you'll know for next time okay I can
hit him from here from downtown yeah
there's three platforms just above the
water that's typically where you're
watching him yeah that's where we right
now hey alright
nope counting for zelda arrow home drop
well drop got him get him tickled his
face dude
pissed yeah his eyes are red that's how
you know I'm just different way here
don't mind me dude this was cool though
this was first time I saw it oh so cool
you think oh I'm in the wrong I got to
be in the middle one dude hey beat this
game sorry I'm beating the Internet
robot it's fine get up on this where's
he at he's coming in hot second pass
that would hurt yeah my shins do you
think I can kill him in two minutes I
doubt it
he's got too many things you got a hit I
feel like I feel like it's two or three
right well looks like both wings and the
head baby
is that right am I crazy sounds right to
me Oh what oh that's nice
dude he didn't do that for me last time
oh what a New Game+ Rob actually that
makes sense you probably have to make
sure you probably got lucky and you're
on the opposite wing that he wasn't like
check just try retrying will give you
one more chance but now you have no
excuses here you know where to go you
know what to do you can't lose two
minutes swimming if he's gonna lose two
minutes women what am I supposed to do
get a jet ski and I was paddling swim
faster well like huh I understand or
maybe I can get Oh what there's
platforms right there see already
learning shaved a minute probably I've
played this game before yeah but you
weren't under the confines of
trying to kill it in five minutes though
you know there's a difference do you
feel like you're totally time-attack
what actually like gives you the value
you would want to replay it or is this
kind of one of those games where you'd
like to beat and you're like good I
almost just drowned um that could happen
in real life too yeah yeah I don't know
man I I guess so
like a lot of this was enjoyable because
of just the mystery of experiencing all
these again I'll killin it on time here
dude get up you yeah hey baby
nope yeah nope yeah killin it
nope yeah god nailed it there we go
that's it that's the one lucky you have
time oh you're coming quick yeah he's
closer Oh what's up Calvin how you doing
I'm doing all right Wednesday playing
games and I work chatting to the people
feels good
[Music]
was he gonna do it is he gonna I think
you're good right now he's not gliding
near the water so you just got a better
act quick yeah cuz he's kind of going on
oh the pass right now but that could
change it okay yeah he's straighten out
yep mm-hmm
there we go that's that's good position
yeah how'd that feel not nice try
spinning that's a cool trick is that
that no okay you do have to hit it again
oh come on dude by the way well just
finish your roll finish you're all
finished you're all calculated now we're
over here no no wait for it
I had a grip on though I know okay okay
breathe breathe breathe it's like we're
going through a pregnancy right now he
is way more difficult than I imagined
really maybe it's that new game+ look at
new game+ life oh dude come on just give
me a second you're stabbing him he's not
gonna give you a second what do you
think this is he's relentless Oh
straight now okay that's great
do you want one more chance or do you
think you can still kill him in the two
minutes that I doubt you can kill him
two minutes right all right last try for
this boss and then I'm gonna and let's
try another boss yeah my favorite it was
so good chat you were so lucky you
realize that right what you don't think
that was yo his there was an clappings
realizing there was there was no skill
in that sick move that was pretty tight
all luck you just have did you aim him
to fall there yeah so I had full control
of that location all right uh-huh
yep don't believe you
maybe if I had more god damn stamina
well hey there's a Time Attack man you
gotta get good as the internet would say
should hit the gym before this I wonder
if the Forbidden Lands has a has like a
24 hour
[Music]
it's pretty tight oh that was so cool
okay so I have to be okay sing to me
says no way he gets it I think this is
the run this is the hashtag the run hey
you wake up see we're already improving
I think I feel like mammy made it so
cool safe all right
[Music]
amy is pissed this is this is exactly
what you would sound like if you're on
this big oh no I know miss birdy if you
really wanted to know how I sound like
these mics would be peaking peaking here
I can turn you down and then you can pee
if you're planning yeah now I'm cool
yeah put your ones in chat if you think
Rob is actually gonna do it this time
put your twos in chat if you don't think
he's gonna do it
put your threes in chat if you think
maybe Wednesday's are sick okay we got
chill Oh God
Oh patience was needed I think someone
said that in chat I agree no oh okay you
just chill baby to bed yep yep get that
balance I'm just gonna hang here for a
little bit you're gonna go the other way
I don't know should I I might done with
that wing yet right you're not I thought
you were I don't see it glowing I can do
that right
Wow bold move cotton if I do that oh
gosh God you got three minutes plenty of
time because I think you start to get
the head to at some point right head I
think it's linked is that the butt of
the tail the butt okay
sure at the but I'm gonna stop I'm gonna
look at chat to fail to says Dustin coat
cook sorry three from anvil Brian Chris
Buchi I don't even know if four is by
the way he's gonna stop going to cover
rust leaving early access possibly real
McCoy not sure blue Frederick gave you
one though
dizzy death gave you one Dacron
one gave you one two it's pretty even I
feel like between the ones on the two
wings but an head I don't know I don't
know if it's the head - are you sure you
still gotta stab this one it's not blue
man I'm wasting time you're right
whoa dude hush might be hush little
birdie this is looking like a big old to
Nick port lo says you got this I'm
pretty sure he does not have this see
look
yeah we wasted a minute on the other
wing but you never know do a barrel roll
whoa oh come on that's what you get you
asked him to do a barrel roll and he did
one I need to set up the camera they do
zoom in on faces so I could show you the
disappointment in Rob's face for like a
hot second like an actual hot second I
think I can I could set one up to two
soo-min on Rob's face here let's
hopefully I don't break the stream doing
this why would I put it down this game
sucks this game sucks I just thanked my
mess with it forget it it's broken
it's that bars and tone uh yeah for
because there's no feet in the game -
right now that's what my brain feels
like right now on something like bars
and did you to volunteer doing this or
we put on this project
ah I mean I just grabbed Rob because I
know he had just beaten it so it was
nice it would be nice to get you know a
fresh perspective in terms of somebody
that didn't play I think
the versions before I feel I feel like
you looked over at me like what was it
Monday morning when I came in I was like
I was like like losing like [ __ ] about
one of the classes - John Luke I was
just like any did dish and it was sick
and you're like hey you want stream it I
was like - I sick this is the run this
is the urn all right this is your last
try on this guy and we're gonna move on
to your arrow other favorite bosses you
know the drill bird
well so far we are getting this part
down to a tee about one minute we get on
him no problem now the next part is both
wings he's so chill about everything
whoa all right so far we've been able to
take this wing down get gay have you
ever considered a collab with casters
from twitch to bring to the office to do
that sort of thing or is there enough
advocates that enjoy streaming the
office that it isn't a real viable
option it's not necessarily not viable
but there's enough people in the office
that want to be on on straight straight
now right now probably want to keep it
within we do other bigger o we do other
industry where we do have twitch
collaborators and youtubers etc come in
and hang out with us but for the most
part the Monday to Friday stuff that we
do here on the GameSpot live is more
just the office for you guys to get hang
out with us and you know chat with us
and meet some new editors or new video
producer etc or that was risky this was
risky or as in Sam's case she's part of
the social team Oh God straighten the
hell out level out level out level out
you still got time I'm not ticking it
all right there there's your level out
just kidding great reactions there don't
listen to me how are you done you're
done right oh hello why are you walking
oh I didn't get it all I don't know it
was still just go just go do you you
okay yeah I was right no blue a
wonderful scent still worry I want to
clip these wings okay is that one done I
think that one that one's done so now it
might be tail and then head you think I
don't think there's an order yeah no I'm
just saying like I think there's just no
right
Wow look at usurp this bird like it's no
problem
pretty sure there's one on the on his
tail though don't mind me bud yeah yep
okay I was right
thank God how do you like it
I've heard a lot oh that really he did
not like that
button head okay so are we are we on to
the next oh come oh yeah oh oh yeah see
dude I'm in 90 seconds left we did it or
well you did it I just I was just here
to I'm on the ride
wow so lucky though that is correct oh
he's going down headfirst Oh No
that's what I call a chicken dinner
alright then we're gonna have to find
one for a fort well what's the name of
love him is it portrayal portrayal
what's the name of this guy is it the
fit Turkey what's the nickname Turkey
wow so lucky says cotter games from that
one gripping part please look it look it
robbed all up on his high horse now
avión maybe give me the black yes his
name is Avion if you're curious which
one are you gonna do now what's the next
one umm who is your next Colossus target
do we want to go to my favorite one yeah
let's do your face he's my favorite I
just had a really good time with him we
got half an hour ish don't you go do
your fav okay
well wait so did you get the arrow since
you beat two of them the whistling arrow
you're supposed to have it maybe not I
don't know I don't know what it said it
said once you defeat two Colossus in
normal mode Time Attack you get the
whistling arrow I'm not hearing large of
a whistle here alright whatever
go go to your favorite wait don't you
have to go find out I think you have to
go into like what the main menu to like
engage it
I think I don't know how to fine okay
which one's my guy I know he's got a
real blocky face where's my guy oh this
is him there's my boy all right well
i'ma wait until you find out great
you're gonna wait I don't have time for
that go to the pool
thanks chat no that's what the video
yeah as answer when the chat says it
nice chat oh hell yeah
look at this glowing stuff that's what
you do in real life right just follow
the glowing stuff oh what's this what's
this data that
can I can I use this in time trial you
guys blind go to the water ia hey
Kakashi
calm down you only have you only have
one good shutting deny the other points
is line deploy the garrison gets the
item oh we got the item all right let's
try out this don't you relax so how do i
oh it's it so now your bone arrow has
that little icon that has like no sonar
thing in it
oh listen that's tight yeah I heard this
is also known as the also known as a
nerf vortex dude yeah listen that thing
was sick the screamer dude I love that
nerve vortex man
ah fun childhood suggests that you know
Rob if you beat four bosses you get the
cloaca force which gives additional
sword damage output which would be
pretty hot so that's two more and it's
two more let's just go look at your
favorite though cuz we've only got about
half an hour and I figure you're gonna
need a couple tries for this one okay
I'm I'm just stalling alright I think
this is my boy right here
he's got what's cool about me is he
doesn't really have any eyes okay come
on you got the bow out probably you're
right
eight minutes and 30 seconds no problem
if we would like to challenge this
Colossus not colossi Colossus
there's a game explain how you have
unlimited arrows no bob who cares I
don't that's what I'm gonna go with and
I'm sticking with it ooh damn he's in
the water this was probably the one
Colossus that colossi that helped
Colossus F this is probably the one
Colossus that
made me go Oh F out loud from one move
and I'll point it out alright
actually you haven't seen this huh nope
okay which which number is this 13 oh
shoot
okay I think maybe someone in chat
because I'm again I'm not that I can
look at okay is it a is it the boar I
want links is it phalanx no no that's
not 13 okay that maybe it's way earlier
then I'll look it up
oh wait maybe I can use that guy to them
yeah I don't know
no he's he's earlier then I'm looking
north they're done Phar Lap Pelageya
plague yeah what number is Oleg yeah the
12th house close he's the twelfth yeah
this might be a little spoilery it's
okay oh you're swimming I didn't even
see you get in the water I'm in it okay
okay
this guy is mildly concerning he's just
so big oh that's a little pro tactic
jump by the water get some air yeah
sorry I marched a music so good
yeah I really is
come on
okay I would be that monster but he's
got no I he's caught her games this who
you really would like to be this one was
just a cool one to figure out so he's
got oh look are those like teeth yeah
right remnants of teeth yeah or
something but like I like to think that
he maybe had like an upper jaw or upper
half of his face ago just reminds me of
those rock bosses in Zelda
go to the mind the or hit that top part
where their weakness is oh crap hey man
you're on a timed thing here
well I this is what you have to do what
do you have to do ooh it's like hitting
his cavity that doesn't feel nice oh you
know it's pretty funny as I was at the
dentist today oh yeah yeah so I ha I can
relate so you're saying you have
cavities he'll know Mikey's tooth my
teeth are great oh man do that knock his
teeth out best teeth my family says my
dentist oh really oh hell yeah dude vote
missed it
don't missed it yep okay that's good
that's good nope oh it's like he's not
dude I'd be pissed it's almost like
messing my cavities tell me about it
alright huh nailed it
this was so cool the first time I was
like alright well what do I do now you
know yeah cuz you can what do you do now
so it's like okay so you can use your
sword right to figure out where its weak
point is no oh okay
he's got laser beams so it's like um
weak spots like on his stomach so was
like alright well then I guess we'll do
this to kill her this ready Oh dip I
like ribcage the first time yeah the
first time I was doing that and we were
just like not because you don't know
what they're gonna do right there so
like lifelike I remember just going oh
oh oh oh my god ah do you get to just do
that now from for the whole time or does
he actually like send you back down
you'll find out
Oh answered my own question
round two oh look he loves it
I'm pretty sure I got stabbed in the
belly button I would not love it that
was pretty cool though
Yeah right just because I've only seen
the first couple so they seemed a little
bit you know more vanilla they they
don't have too much going on yet but I
sure having some laser beams is pretty
pretty nasty they're good starts as
Kakashi Thank You Kakashi senpai please
I'm Naruto what's this guy's name again
it's the nickname huh lakeya or
something busy is what kind of animal is
he is he like some sort of like tooth
boar let me see like I'm like I'm maybe
like a like a yak developers nickname
for it was Poseidon oh right I have no
idea does it does it say like what kind
of animal is him little I like to think
he's like a boar nope
he's like a mutant fish frog so he's got
horns oh I'm doing this wrong yeah you
got a I was expecting I don't I'm so
used to like going to their heads and
just got a plate where I can pick beats
off his teeth yeah it beats beats by
wander see I figured out what's going
off here you're you're gonna need a
filling here that's great like kinda
seems a little bit too easy though is
the fact that the teeth kind of keep you
on on it head yeah like it would be a
little bit more scary if if you were
like potentially knocked off oh he did
not like that what does it seem like
you're going away from yeah Oh does that
shift where his head is yes the whole
thing if you direct him with
with his teeth with his horrible teeth
oh we're ski that's that risky no this
guy has my favorite attacks so far I
think is what Cotter gave them to me
yeah this guy means busy
how watch me that big belly of yours hey
how come he doesn't shoot the laser or
did he shoot the laser and I missed it
looking at I think he's just trying to
be intimidating mama once the laser
attack again it's kind of a shame that
didn't happen but whatever I'll good
come on Rob hey whoa that did some work
you have three minutes
I don't know if you'll kill him here oh
oh damn so no that's that's not too
normal I'm pretty sure that's not Oh cuz
you're in the next phase of like
wherever yet there oh boy you know
what's up now it's like wait a second
it sees damn for that form it's just god
damn alright do you think you're doing
it three minutes no damn oh let me just
you should be getting shocked if that
was real life
dude living that Zelda life you should
be like you know exactly one of those
one of those two things that we just did
two minutes 30 seconds
finish what you started I will French
what'd you think about that solo trailer
mm-hmm I still haven't watched the full
one yet really yeah
whoops Oh Melissa tease I kind of like
the Super Bowl teaser a little more yeah
cuz there's less like if there's more
prime more mystery yeah no but I love
that one shot of the Train and that
destiny ass guy uh yeah he's cool I
don't know you know people are saying oh
it doesn't look like Han Solo or a
Harrison Ford or act like I'm I don't
think we haven't seen anything but also
I don't know like oh come on like if it
was like excessively Oh like Harrison
Ford I think that would be uh maybe a
little distracting like do it Doug I
often close on everything I'm closing oh
yeah why do you oh oh yeah all right
didn't like it
hey I'm up here show me your belly where
is it
oh it's a belly butter cord okay
90 seconds I guess it really comes down
to if you if you think you can get like
two good actual stabs in because like if
not I don't know oh you did a baby stab
yeah yeah Wow no problem one shot
where's try I would have given you a
legit high-five that's fine my hands are
little so clammy
yeah mine are and I'm not even playing
so well you think you want to do one
more try to get that that cloak you can
do the an easy one if you want or you
can do a cool one if you want do you do
you want to see a smaller one sure you
do whatever you want man the world is
your oyster I'm merely an observer
[Music]
bunker Marth hey guys not sure if this
has been explained yet but have they
added any mechanics to the fruit you can
find in this game like more mechanics
it's just health as far as I know and
they taste delicious
just chat want to see a smaller guy or
should we do something a little more uh
not a spoilery like a like an early its
health and strength meters
oh that makes sense actually because
when we replayed it I had my health for
New Game+ and I was definitely my damage
was definitely increased snake oh wait
that's weird hold on there isn't much to
do here but what's this I guess there's
apparently fruit of the Dead - and
they'd like will decrease your strength
so that it doesn't block too much of
your fob fo be off small a little
smaller guys should we should do a small
pick who you want Rose waiting for chat
- con respeto smaller one guy says
smaller guy problem Eric is that you
don't go there representation of sizes
in there what do you mean I can tell
that that guy's small I don't know
really one let's just do an early one
and see if we get this thing because the
obviously the are you doing the giraffe
guy well considering time yeah you know
they increase like they do the sword guy
to if you thinking and that's what's
[Music]
okay who's that just don't know what
these bird we did snake so once a
snicker small guy this will be my first
time playing this game but first need to
finish monster a good luck with that is
right
moco from punker Marth to mo carry that
game is I'm not even I haven't even
unlock the second rank of tempered beast
or tempered monsters at because I got a
do a quest but there's like three sets
of tempered monsters
and to snake other stuff it's just it is
a long game it just depends on what you
consider beating the game if you're just
finishing the first story arc or the
actual game will take you like 60 to 70
hours this was nine minutes but to get
to a true end game there's some there's
some crazy stuff oh we're doing this now
people really want that snake alright so
once a turtle too late sorry right
doesn't ride the snake like return for
heroin I am right oh I did the wrong
snake yeah
let's do this one okay wrong snake he
says oh were they thinking of the desert
snake do I want you guys want me to
cancel and do the desert snake sure
skip the cinematic and then exit out I
guess
oh [ __ ] that was a spoiler and itself
right there and Raul Jimenez says I'm
assuming that's a minute sorry if that
I'm saying it wrong snake please by the
way cream so far thank you this is more
of an eel so oh yeah okay that's fair
yeah that's electricity right yeah eels
are electric as far as my apology goes
here zoologist I'm a zoologist I got an
a-plus in zoology in college thanks
Connor games is this the right did you
find the right snake yeah this looks
pretty literary this is our dude this
guy was tough I had to turn on the
doorman hints because I couldn't figure
it out it was pretty obvious in a way I
just that just didn't come to mind yeah
what's going on here I grow I grow up
nice Kakashi
oh this looks this is like oh he's not
that long you know I thought that he'd
be bigger well assuming that was his
actual tail but he did not look like
maybe he's a very lengthy maybe maybe
he's a baby well baby snake I don't like
a baby
Colossus snake maybe he's like a
mealworm gross 5 minutes 30 seconds Rob
on it I go let's go I get off run
oh ho ho oh ho oh maybe you should
whistling arrow his ass no don't do it
just just beat him well I oh oh he's
comin oh there is it's like a shark let
me guess you're supposed to run him into
these rocks that's what I was thinking
no it's not no damn it's it's it's one
of those things were just like so
plainly obvious I knew I had to some of
the horse this is this oh hello sir oh
right in the eyeball yeah that was it
that was the key huh yep the eyes go go
figure the eyes they're pretty important
though Rob and the eyes are pretty
important Oh
see you later aggro girl get out of here
boo right there there's a spot yep
how fortuitous your problem is you got
something right here that didn't hurt
that bad it's a present I think yeah you
gotta get in that a little circle the
eyes are always soft it says group
usually pretty weird if they weren't I
guess I only feel like it if you had
like a glass eye you know definitely
that's made of glass Oh bye-bye half of
your life now
oh how girl you need him again hi girl
yeah yeah get the move sick moves you
led me to believe you're gonna do some
type of like flip onto a girl and you
did not lose a gross fault show me those
beautiful beautiful orange eyes baby oh
you get either one oh yeah yeah oh look
he loves it oh oh oh my health just went
down oh wow that's a lot of oh yeah I
forgot this guy this guy gimme uh gave
me a hard time all right
let me get that sword out feel like
assuming you can do as much as you did
last time he should be dead here but you
know considering you still have 3
minutes and 30 seconds I feel like wow
this is really effing dark I can barely
see it are to me things it's actually
underneath him
got you not remembering because my
memory is [ __ ] bad oh I'm wrong
oh don't you fall off yet I can't even
see where the hell you are you know it
might be these got these a dam filters
on it's a little better is it I can't at
least kind of see where you're at
oh there I see you oh hello
I love your tat oh yeah baby it's
probably gonna kick me off now oh oh oh
oh oh Reilly's gay auto parts what
happens if you go past the gold timer I
would assume you'd fail and maybe it
would tell you to restart we haven't
actually gotten to that point but I mean
that has to be the assumption right run
run rob don't let him get you you're
never gonna catch me all right screams
very dark yeah I can't do much about it
it was the filter try to change it there
haha
Oh Riley's Paige scream I wish it's not
all right so let's oh you want to see if
it makes a difference I don't know how
you're gonna tell though I just I wanna
see what it looks like oh yeah yeah yeah
you think it's like a different color
cloak or something definitely want to
pick it up know where we stopped it yeah
definitely and also it better be
something different it better be
oh man Rob's gonna lose it
I'm not gonna skip this oh oh we didn't
even see better what it was like I was
like remember we're like how do we act
access it it was it showed I showed it
to it I probably skipped it god damn
pool
what's with the effing stuff try not to
get to monetize or something yeah just
try not to say the f-word no need
there's there's plenty of other words
that can evoke the same emotion ooh
what's this
but it'll we're hanging us out to dry
look as cool as yours you don't know yet
it's soaking wet I know what doesn't got
any lines on it it doesn't what else I
bet it smells like [ __ ] so this is just
damaged yeah it was supposed to be more
sword damage I believe increases the
amount of damage your sword will do yep
to a Colossus did you equip it it's the
same isn't that the same cloak I think a
couple of these I have to I got to go to
the main menu maybe Jack and can answer
that we have to we have to see it I know
it's not on chat how do you know it's
not on alright cuz it because it looks
exactly the same
yeah well so I mean that I guess the
arrow did look different huh yeah
totally did I had a head of a nerf or
checks on it
[Music]
it sounds like a train whistle
Chad help us out can I put this fit on
says just equip it let's see Oh items
yeah just equip it to reap the benefits
it does look the same well let's see if
it is that it's slightly different
I think the pattern is slightly
different right am I crazy yeah I think
so but it's not that much all right
let's check all right so that's kind of
got like a diamond-shaped thingy where's
the camera could help us out let me just
do this all right okay so so it's like
I'll it's like a diamond thingy yeah
with shapes around it fastens Creed type
thing sure sure sure okay it's got its
got shapes on it okay and then oh yeah
oh man they the old one looks cooler
normal yeah I know it looks cooler don't
you think wrong wrong I know many bro
god dammit what's that mask oh that's I
want to say thing the Queen oh there's
flash arrows what is this Monster Hunter
yeah ooh cloak of deception whoo it's
very powerful yeah fully charged stab is
enough to take out one weak spot okay
but that's hard mode though oh look that
sword yeah the Queen's sword oh look at
that yeah that's the queen sword that's
the one oh wow you know with our minds
is like no just cuz I've had my fair
share of Wow looks like the ancient like
saw one yeah flash arrows got like a
little bomb on it yeah man that's like a
that's like a harpoon as it says they're
a thunder though Oh Thunder you guys
yeah you got a map hacker for lizards
yeah a nice little ugly lizard map packs
for fruits you have some dank weed legal
here some desperate cloth what's real
desperate where do you put where it
smells like desperation rug yes
John Doe cookies five messages for me to
respond to you know you get a little
statue don't know this is to shoot oh I
didn't know there was a I didn't know
there's arrested a girl either what's
different about him
he's Crested bro so he's got like scales
she's got like scales all right cool
all right well I guess that's about it
that's awesome uh you know thank you so
much Rob for yet yep use the nerve
vortex Oh kill that audio one second oh
my gosh alright let me go back to the
gaming pit I went to full camera to say
goodbye but here's Rob trying to shoot
birds that he can't kill because it'll
die alright anyways thank you guys all
for tuning in to the live stream today
we'll be back tomorrow at 11:00 a.m. I
actually haven't chosen the game yet mr.
and Friday might actually get so we
usually have Monster Hunter Mondays
which is a great name by the way but the
event and weekly stuff refreshes on
Friday so I might actually have been and
John Luke move it to Friday and we'll
switch money to something else so stay
tuned for that all that stuff folks
thank you guys or thank you rob Bradshaw
for you doing such a hot job with those
timed attacks yeah
any final thoughts on your shadow
Colossus remake experience this game is
really awesome if you have not played it
or even if you're a fan of it I'm sure
it's worth a replay and it's definitely
worth picking out what made $40 it's
like that that's pretty good
for you know even played this game I
would highly recommend it because it's a
blast and I definitely want to play it
again sometime awesome thanks guys and
thank you rob later